you called Paul and said Paul would you
come over and listen to my album I was
telling the story how you and I were
talking about it we were at a restaurant
and as you were telling me this story by
coincidence
Paul McCartney walked in right behind
you and I go John yeah look over your
shoulder that's how McCartney and you're
like hey Beatle Paul come on over here I
mean but what do you think he likes you
calling him Beatle Paul I was thinking
about he asks it's funny guys just ran
into him again whenever you run into him
you know you've become a teenage fan and
I was with him and we went to see the
Eagles clay and I said Beatle Paul he
said why do you call me Beatle Paul I
says because I'm too old to call you mr.
McCartney and I'm too in reverence to
dare think that you know we're that
close that I can call you Paul so I said
let's like your majesty or Beatle Paul
anyway okay because because a needle for
God's sake and I know yeah also one of
the sweetest guys you've ever met in
your life so what do you do Paul comes
over do you just stare at him while he's
listening to music so Paul shows up by
himself and we sit on the couch and I
claim a bunch of songs from the
forthcoming record and because I'm so
proud of it I had no issue playing it
for him and I had just written a song
because there had been a couple
shootings in El Paso and Dayton Ohio
over a weekend that I had written a song
that I hadn't yet recorded but I was so
excited about this song and I'm so proud
of it but I actually picked up my guitar
and played the front and that is
something that eighteen year old me
might have done but 50 year old me would
have been too scared and and and I did
and I sat with him and played it now
he's a lefty so he's flipping my guitar
over and talking through this song with
me after I played it and you know I mean
you're sitting there in your mind
playing it over and over and over
because it's it's beautiful and when
Paul is sitting and listening to your
new album and you're proud of it and you
what are you looking for you're looking
for him to start tapping his toe to Bob
his head what do you I mean what is he
doing at that point and and are you
completely focused on staring at him
because to me this is it sounds like
torture
to be watching Paul McCartney
listen to something you just gave birth
though I think you stare at the speaker
cones like because you don't know what
you want to look at him but you don't
know
you